françois costantini docteur en sciences
politiques spécialisés de relations
internationales
françois costantini merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
trois semaines maintenant que les
combats ont commencé une trêve sans
effet qu'est-ce qui pourrait dénouer la
situation d'une façon ou d'une autre
aujourd'hui bien ce conflit entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan sur le
karabakh est différent des précédents
parce que cette fois ci à l'origine du
conflit et et expliquant également sa
densité plus aiguë que qu'auparavant
c'est l'implication directe de la
turquie erdogan on sait les stratégies
belliciste tous azimuts sur plusieurs
fronts en méditerranée orientale en
syrie en libye
et là il ya littéralement poussé
l'azerbaïdjan à l'affrontement et on
sait aujourd'hui que pour m en mai c'est
en mettant la turquie à la raison qu'on
arrêtera le conflit puisque le conflit
n'est pas seulement une affaire de
cessez-le-feu entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
c'est que l'azerbaïdjan était
littéralement mis sous tutelle par la
turquie il ya eu des manoeuvres à partir
dans l'important dolan acuna catch
alliance s est cette région à 0 qui
s'est tu sur le flanc méridional de 2,2
de l'arménie est que cette fois ci en
effet on est on est plus seulement dans
on voit notamment que les négociations à
moscou patine parce que en effet les
azéris sont littéralement placé sous
sous le commandement et du fait de
l'armement d instruction militaire est
également des des milliers de
djihadistes syriens qui ont été envoyés
en sur le sur le front une part par la
turquie sont donc sous la soul à coude
d'ankara et c'est là dessus que achopper
les négociations
justement il avait fallu plusieurs jours
en guise aux diplomates du groupe de
minsk pour obtenir que l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie accepte d'endosser le texte a
basé sur les accords de moscou du samedi
précédent
atex qui est elle-même pour les deux
parties alors que proposer maintenant
mais a proposé tout simple c'est que il
va falloir condamné notamment les
agressions de de la turquie le fait que
la poule la turquie a poussé poussé à
l'affrontement est en effet la russie
est plus jeune et parce que la russie a
un rôle plutôt médiateur
on dit qu'elle penche du côté de
l'arménie s'est pas tout à fait exact
elle a toujours un rôle médiateur elle a
fourni d'ailleurs elle fournit
d'ailleurs plus d'art en proportion à
l'azerbaïdjan cas l'arménie par les
contrats traditionnels mais là il est il
est certain que la question se pose avec
l'implication directe de la turquie
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut poser faire
pression notamment sur la turquie et
faire en sorte que l impose ou du moins
qu'elle stoppe en tout cas l'offensive
azéri mais ne sont pas que ce soit
actuellement dans ses plans justement
dans ce contexte du coup qu'est ce qu'on
peut attendre de moscou selon vous
quelles interventions avec quels leviers
béa c'est le problème je pense qu'en
effet cette alliance contre nature entre
la turquie et la russie se trouve
aujourd'hui en quelque sorte c'est tout
toutes ses limites
en effet il ya eu également une la
stratégie européenne qui a quelque peu
poussé la russie dans dans les bras la
turquie son petit c'est une alliance qui
allons voir moyen terme contre nature
mais en effet il va falloir que je pense
qu'il faut que la russie choisissent
davantage et qu'elle en est là en effet
un avantage elle a en effet un outil en
main qui est sa relation avec avec
ankara et qu'elle s'adresse directement
en quarts a justement pour mettre fin
aux hostilités je pense que c'est c'est
là c'est là dessus qu'il faudra insister
puisque l'azerbaïdjan aujourd'hui a été
relancé
quitte à le redire encore une fois à
relancer le confie justement par la
seule influence de la turquie donc c'est
une médiation plutôt russo turcs eux qui
s'impose qui sera moins la vie beaucoup
plus fortes et qui aura plus de porter
qu'une sa médiation à 0 arménienne et la
turquie elle restera fidèle à
l'azerbaïdjan
oui bien sûr vous savez qu'ils les
airbags j'en avais eu toujours une
politique d'autonomie au plan politique
au plan économique elle avait essayé de
bâtir et que président aliev sa propre
puissance à une politique notamment
d'investissements dans les dents les px
et anto grâce grâce au gaz dans un
certain nombre de ceux de société mais
là il là il apparaît comme que
l'azerbaïdjan père est en quelque sorte
le pré carré qu'il avait mis peut être
10 15 ans
à dessiner et qu'il est retombé en
quelque sorte dans dans la logique tenta
tentaculaire d'erdogan ce qui est à mon
sens une erreur de la part des
dirigeants azéri parce que il avait une
chance d'avoir une originalité
diplomatique un quant-à-soi politiques
et stratégiques
et ils sont en train de le perdre et je
pense à leurs dépends parce que je pense
que l'azerbaïdjan n'a pas à gagner dans
deux dans cette guerre c'est à dire que
même s'il ya des reconquêtes m pour être
que partielle et ne peuvent pas gagner
de façon absolue absolue face à
l'arménie donc je pense que en effet
l'azerbaïdjan c'est en quelque sorte à
insérer dans la logique actuelle n'est
ottomane de d'erdogan et plus seulement
des pentures 6 avec l'azerbaïdjan mais
on également dans une logique les hôtes
néo ottomane qui va loin et je pense que
c'est là dessus sur cette relation avec
la turquie que l'azerbaïdjan a pris un
certain nombre de risques d'appui aux
cibles et de risques paris et washington
ont les moyens de faire pression sur la
turquie dans ce dossier ils ont que
d'amener diplomatique un paris
washington et moscou il faut rappeler
comme vous l'avez du co préside le
groupe de contact de deux mines sq qui a
été mis en place si ma mémoire est bonne
en 1994 à la suite du du conflit de 1992
mais le bleu groupe n'a fait qu'activer
en quelque sorte les les canaux
diplomatiques et en effet c'est une
pression beaucoup plus forte sur sur la
turquie de la part notamment de paris de
washington des pays européens est de
moscou qui devrait s'exercer pour que
cessent ces hostilités puisque des clés
de l'os des hostilités ne sont pas à
erevan à bas coûts mais plutôt en quarts
donc c'est là plutôt que doit se se
concentraient les discussions et les
pressions diplomatiques
alors en attendant de futures
discussions ou de pressions s qui en
attendant on doit craindre un véritable
bain de sang pour les populations
civiles
lewis est à craindre c'est le genre de
conflit vous avez c'est un cas compliqué
par clairement meurtrier depuis
pratiquement une trentaine d'années
puisqu'on parle de 92 me
le conflit a même prêt à exister à la
chute de l'urss
c'est en 1988 que sont apparues les
premières tensions sur le nagorny
karabakh
donc on en effet c'est une logique
d'affrontement deux peuples qui sont
fondamentalement hostile qui sont
irréductibles l'un à l'autre de deux
cultures différents un peuple en plus
ils peuvent par millien qui directement
a souffert nage une aussi
particulièrement atroces perpétrés par
lecture qu'il ya un siècle
donc qui est une question défense je
vous rappellerai toujours ce ce fameux
mot de sakharov qui disait le nagorny
karabakh pour l'arménie c'est une
question de vie et de mort merci
beaucoup françois constantine nous avoir
éclairé je rappelle que vous êtes
docteur en sciences politiques et
spécialiste des relations
internationales